Hello and welcome the fire of learning.
So there's some confusion centered around this country.
Here is this place called the Netherlands or Holland are the way that people
aren't necessarily called Nederlanders or Hollander's,
but they are in fact the Dutch.
Why is this so confusing?
Well,
simply put,
the names are so odd because the region has had a very shifting and turbulent
history.
The first point I want to make is that it's not really their fault.
It's the fault of us English speakers in Dutch,
the word Dutch is near Lonza.
The Dutch people are donated or launders and the country is Nader lawn,
although occasionally the Dutch do call their country Holland.
The second point is that the Danish,
the NHANES Denmark,
everything from this country here is not related,
so don't get them confused.
Now then,
what's the difference between the Netherlands and Holland?
Well,
technically speaking,
Holland refers to north and South Holland,
the two most important provinces in the Netherlands,
home to many important cities,
including the Capitol,
Amsterdam.
This is similar to people at times referring to the United Kingdom as England,
it has a times,
however,
been used correctly.
Do describe the whole country as early as the 11th century in fact,
and as recently as Napoleon renaming the country to the Kingdom of Holland to
this day,
and I said the Dutch still occasionally referred to their whole country as
Holland and it's not completely incorrect to do so in English though not favored
because there are of course 10 other provinces is sides north and south Holland
within the country.
The term the Netherlands means the low countries referring to the low altitude
of the nation,
though the term originally referred to a large region which include a Belgium
and other parts of the area.
The name however,
was eventually adopted as the national name of the Dutch republic.
Speaking of which the Dutch,
the word Dutch shares a common origin.
What the German word Dortch which means German.
The old dramatic word say,
oh,
disc meant simply the people and became Deutsche in German.
Likewise,
the Danish and Swedish referred to Germans as tick.
The Dutch people closely related to the other dramatic peoples of Europe were
eventually called the Dutch by English speakers.
Terms like deach were used by the Dutch and their own language to refer to
themselves,
at least terms were eventually abandoned in favor of Nadir Lonza.
Interestingly,
however,
the Pennsylvania Dutch,
a group of Amish and Mennonites living in Pennsylvania,
I'm not actually Dutch,
the German and the name is a remnant of a time when the words Dutch and
Deutsche,
we're not so very far apart and highlights the fact that they share a common
origin.
Again,
referring to variations of dramatic words for people.
And so that is the answer to these questions in a nutshell,
to support the creation of more videos like these,
a link to our patriotic we found in the channels description,
any donation would be appreciated and be put to use to improve the channel.
For more videos like these and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.